Hi, I'm Joel list. And this is Mark Norman.
We're here in San Diego trying to grow our podcasts.
A lot of people have been writing negative comments saying that we're not as big
as we should be.
So we're taking the podcast to the streets and we're going to get some new fans,
the old fashioned way. Let's go make some new fans. Hey guys,
you guys, uh, you like podcasts Christ or podcast, man. We're good, man.
I'm good. Thanks. Come on,
drew. Carey. What about the dogs?
I don't know.
Mark wants for help. Go away. You guys like podcasts?
Golden girls. You like podcasts?
Hello?
Ah, we're like that. We're similar. We're two American lives.
Tuesdays with stories. Have you heard of that one? You know? Ha ha E sorry.
Mark. Norman and myself. Jimmy Kimmel.
It's on a YouTube tunes. Grinder. The dog legged.
I think you're going to like it. Good luck in bed.
Would you like to hear a clips? No.
Pretty good. Right?
How bad do you wanna hear the rest of the hour? Um, I'm kind of busy right now.
I see. You got to get to the point faster. You guys are just talking. You just.
Calling women. I like.
It kind of like seed the pants. You know, that kind of thing.
I can't see myself just listening to two straight guy.
You seem like great guys. I'm sure. You're nice guys. Yet.
We do a lot of volunteer work with the children.
We only have 11 fans were related to all of them. Your loss now the new fan,
maybe just that clip. I don't know. Okay. It was a bad clip. I'm sorry.
He's on the tonight. Show Thursday. Yeah. Check it out.
I'll be doing that clips. Do slate stories. Who's live with your stories.
Okay, sir. Tuesdays with the stories.
Martha cone stories like Tuesdays with Morrie. Yeah, the funnier.
And we say less than light. A little more slurs. Yeah.
Is there anybody that doesn't mind the seaward? A lot of.
Anal count is how do you see words that like the C word.
You guys are like Sirius XM, Opie and Anthony.
We wish they get paid and you guys are still in Washington square asking for
people. Yeah. We're desperate. Get your podcasts. Here is my agent. Oh. Oh,
okay. That makes sense.
It's paradigm for a podcaster nickel for a pod free podcast
money.
Well-spent have you ever heard the podcast Tuesdays with stories you've heard
of. Wow, it's great. I will listen to that. Hey. Yes. You're the first one.
That's a scrubbed all day. Check out our website to comedian,
Joe lists.com and brazzers.com.
Old school single.
Oh, Hey. I'm Shane Gillis. They listened long time.
Well, little a TV show. It's called the Savia teen talk show.
Savia means stop anger, unfold, violence, educate and regime.
Yes. Here. Oh my God. I hope he doesn't listen there. You have it folks.
Another successful day in Washington, square park, getting some new fans.
You got that right? Whole batch, a new two's gaze out there.
This pod is going to be bigger than my Dick. So not that big,
but spotty and contagious.
One in four threaten I'll get the balls on that thing, Mike. Wow. Yeah,
that dog too. Let me see if I can still a kickflip been a couple of,
Oh geez. You do it all. A blow you witness.
Oh, how about that? I got to blow.
Get those pants off.